in kharkiv der zweitgrößten ukrainischen
stadt soll das leben ein stück weit
normalität zurück bekommen nachdem die
ukrainischen streitkräfte die russen
auch dort ein stück weit zurück trennen
konnten doch viele haben angst die
schutzräume in denen sie sich teils seit
monaten versteckt haben zu verlassen die
metro zum beispiel die lehrerin
anastasia zum beispiel unser reporter
bahn stritzel hat sie getroffen
hf ein symbol für putins krieg gegen die
ukraine doch jetzt eine wende nach der
erfolgreichen gegenoffensive der
ukrainischen armee ist die stadt wieder
unter kontrolle
normalität stadt kriegsverbrechen die
metro soll wieder fahren und die
menschen sollen den schützenden
untergrund wieder verlassen rückblick
wochen lang steht die ukrainische stadt
unter beschuss unaufhörlich schlagen
putins bomben und raketen ein töten
zivilisten zerstören wohnhäuser der
einzige schutz für die menschen die
metro hier suchen sie seit monaten
schutz vor putins bomben die metro wird
zum lebensmittelpunkt der menschen hier
verbringen sie ihren tag hier essen und
schlafen sie hier feiern sie kinder
geburtstage und hochzeiten
jetzt also sollen die zivilisten den
schutz im untergrund verlassen und haben
angst angst vor einem erneuten angriff
der russischen armee sowie diese familie
vater und mutter tatjana und tochter in
sie ziehen jetzt zurück in ihre wohnung
danke ich habe gemischte gefühle
es ist immer gut heim zu kommen aber ein
bisschen beängstigend wegen den
beschüssen und den raketen obwohl es
unwahrscheinlich ist getroffen zu werden
wir frauen sind einfach ängstlich ich
muss heim weil die arbeiter gesagt haben
dass die metro bald wieder fährt deshalb
müssen wir jetzt heim auch nastia
fürchtet sich davor die schützende metro
wieder verlassen zu müssen
ich habe große angst weil ich allein
wirklich allein bin ich habe nur meine
freundin natascha sie hilft mir mit
allem deshalb hoffe ich dass alles gut
wird
die menschen in rage sie haben angst
aber auch die hoffnung dass sie nie
wieder zurück müssen in die metro vom
frage
[Musik]
dort in der metro von prag ist unser
reporter björn stritzel björn du warst
vor wochen dort in kharkiv und jetzt
wieder wie hat sich die situation in der
stadt verändert aus deiner sicht
also generell hat man einfach den
eindruck dass hier profan gesagt das
leben wieder zurückkehrt in die stadt
also sind viele zehntausende menschen
zurückgekehrt das ist nicht nur eine
solche depressive stimmung wie es noch
vor vor drei vier wochen hier in der
stadt war das hängt eben damit zusammen
dass auch die äußeren rand bezirke der
stadt nicht mehr bombardiert werden weil
die ukrainische truppen die russischen
invasion zurückgeworfen haben und
deswegen gern hier immer mehr menschen
zurück wo wir jetzt aber gerade stehen
in dieser metro wo viele hunderte bis
tausende menschen ausgeharrt haben in
solchen metro stationen während des
bombardements da hat sich heute früh
etwas abgespielt ja das kann man schon
so ein kleines drama nennen denn die
leute die hier hin geflüchtet waren die
haben hier teilweise bis zu mehr als
zwei monate verbracht in diesen waggons
hinter mir mussten heute früh diese
waggons verlassen als sie hatten früh
die anweisung bekommen von den behörden
diese waggons zu räumen weil in den
nächsten tagen auch die metro wieder
starten soll
wir haben die ukrainische armee meldet
weitere erstaunliche erfolge wir schauen
uns das man kurz an bevor wir weiter
sprechen
putins blutiger angriffskrieg in der
ukraine
er läuft nicht nach plan und das seit
monaten die großoffensive im osten der
ukraine verpufft
zehntausende tote soldaten tausende
zerstörte fahrzeuge und panzer
marginale geländegewinne das ist die
verheerende bilanz der russen
jetzt erreichen uns bilder die bis vor
kurzem niemand für möglich gehalten
hätte
ukrainische soldaten schlagen bei kif
feindliche truppen zurückstoßen vor bis
zur russischen grenze
dieses video zeigt ukrainische soldaten
an einem grenzfall zu russland die
recken die faust freuen sich über ihren
erfolg den rückschlag des feindes dieses
video es ist ein symbol für den mut der
ukraine ein symbol für putins scheitern
die erfolgreiche gegenoffensive der
ukraine sie erwischt die russen kalt
nicht nur soldaten schaffen es bis zur
russischen grenze sogar hubschrauber
wagen sich in den ukrainisch-russischen
grenzbereich können nahezu ungestört
operieren
die von putin totgesagte ukrainische
luftwaffe sie lebt die russischen
luftabwehr hingegen ganz und gar nicht
vorbereitet auf die unerwarteten
vorstöße der ukraine despot putin
reagiert verzweifelt und selbst
geächtete waffen ein er bombardiert dass
auf stahlwerk mit phosphorbomben
und er schickt tschetschenische kämpfer
an die front freiwillige aus
tschetschenien das sind ganz offizielle
aufnahmen hier vom flughafen großen
flughafen großen niveau gestern sich
tausende tschetschenische freiwillige
aufgemacht haben und wir sehen uns hier
ja siegessicher aber ich bin auch völlig
unbedacht gehen dir tausende
tschetschenische ländliche bewohner in
die maschinen der russischen luftwaffe
werden in richtung ukraine geführt und
sollen dann dort ganz offenbar als
kanonenfutter für putins
steckengebliebene militäroffensive im
osten des landes herhalten die schlacht
um den osten der ukraine
sie ist trotz der mobilisierung
tschetschenische kämpfer nicht
entschieden es sind diese bilder und die
den ukrainern hoffnung geben hoffnung
auf einen weg finden und ihn und seine
armee
wir waren unglaublich wenn man diese
bilder sieht am anfang des krieges
dachte man dass eine sache von tagen bis
die russen die ukraine eingenommen
hätten und jetzt der fast ungläubige
gedanke kann die ukraine womöglich nicht
nur verteidigen sondern diesen krieg am
ende tatsächlich gewinnen
also zumindest sieht es in einigen
regionen sehr gut aus also wir haben es
gerade angesprochen in hf da ist es
einigen ukrainische truppen gelungen bis
zur russischen grenze vorzustoßen und
wir haben in den vergangenen tagen wenn
wir da im umland waren in einigen dieser
dörfer wonach kämpfe beziehungsweise in
den angrenzenden dörfern auch mehrfach
helikopter gesehen der ukrainischen
luftwaffe die dort operiert haben und
das ist eigentlich etwas was man vor
zwei monaten noch für unmöglich gehalten
hätte dass sie dort tatsächlich in
solcher nähe russischer truppen
konzentration luft operationen
durchführen können dass die russische
luftabwehr offensichtlich nicht in der
lage ist die unten zu halten
das scheint auch einer der gründe zu
sein warum warum diese gegenoffensive so
erfolgreich ist der andere grund dürfte
sein dass
putin sich tatsächlich etwas
verkalkuliert hat was so die
produktionsweise seiner generalität sich
verkalkuliert hat was die anzahl an
benötigten soldaten angelangt nicht aus
dem aus den belagerungsring nördlich von
cardiff da wurden in den vergangenen
wochen einheiten abgezogen um
nachschubrouten zu sichern wurden weiter
nach osten verlegt und die ukraine haben
das haben das ausgenutzt haben dann
sofort mit einer gegenoffensive begonnen
mit kleinen einheiten unterstützen
artilleriefeuer und zuletzt eben auch
von durch luftoperationen es geschafft
die russischen stellungen dort
aufzureiben dort mehrere dörfer wieder
zurückzuerobern und ich bin mir nicht
ganz sicher ob diese einigen tausend
freiwilligen aus stehen ob das dann
einen solch entscheidender unterschied
sein wird was was diese offensive
fähigkeiten der russischen armee
anbelangt in den nächsten wochen also da
wird das wird glaube ich tatsächlich ja
wenn überhaupt ein tropfen auf den
heißen stein sein allerdings in einigen
anderen landesteilen sieht es
tatsächlich für die russischen
streitkräfte nicht ganz so schlecht aus
wie hier beitrag also etwas weiter
östlich ist es tatsächlich so dass sie
da in ihm drin was doch einige dörfer
einigen boden gut gemacht haben wenn
auch wenngleich auch viel viel weniger
als sie als sie selber verkündet hatten
noch vor einigen wochen die schritte aus
der metrostation in krakau wo bis heute
morgen noch menschen schutz gesucht
haben kharkiv wo ein stück weit das
leben zurückgekehrt ist